the idea of a taxi cab came to me this
yellow metal coffin floating through the
sewer of the city with this boy trapped
inside who can't get out who looks like
he's in a crowd but he's desperately
alone I said that's who I am I'm the kid
in that cab and I wrote that story as
self-therapy because I had to create
this character or else I was going to
become him I really don't care if you
guys can write or not because you can
learn to write what I care about is your
problems and if you can refine what's
unique about your problems one of the
ways you refine this is through the
metaphor then you have a Channel of
uniqueness a metaphor is something that
stands apart from the problem yet is
somehow linked to its Secret in fact
easier now to make a slow film because
people are so geared or a barrage of
visual and audio information that you
just have to slow down a little and
you're disrupting them a lot it's simply
what happens when you take a problem and
drive it through a metaphor you can have
a script that's extremely well written
you can have the same story poorly
written and they can both be a great
film so it isn't so much about the
writing itself as it is about the story
foreign
I was in a a kind of a dark place
uh drinking and driving
I didn't have a place to live I had a
gun in the car
and uh
I had a a pain in my stomach I went to
the hospital and it was a bleeding
holster at the age of 26.
and I realized in an emergency room that
I hadn't spoken to anybody in weeks and
I had just been drifting through the
city with these anger here in town in
Los Angeles
and with all this anger
and so I realized that it was time
I had to turn to fiction in order to get
out of this place I had to create this
character or else I was going to become
him and that character was Travis Bickle
and the idea of
the taxicab came to me this yellow metal
coffin floating through the sewer of the
city with this boy trapped inside
who can't get out who looks like he's in
a crowd but he's desperately alone
and I said that's who I am I'm the kid
in that cab and I wrote that story as
self-therapy because I figured if I can
write about it I don't have to become
him
and it worked
uh as I wrote about him he became more
and more detached for me when I teach
screenwriting
I use it for the first class I give a
sort of lecture like this one
and um
and then I ask everyone to write down
and no more than
two sentences each they're two most
pressing personal problems at this
moment
say I will not be able to take all of
you we're only going to have 10 kids in
the class and I really don't care if you
guys can write or not
because you can learn to write
what I care about is your problems if
you are in the class
your problems will become the joint
property of the class
if you're not in the class thrown away I
forgot
that often it clears out a certain
number of them
and uh
and then you know we start
to talk about writing
to around maybe five or six weeks in
it's all about
therapy and group therapy and how art
can
how you can use
the medium of Storytelling
to understand your problems better and
the one thing that you have that is
unique to you
is your problem because even if it's the
same problem of the guy next to you
know self-image
I can't tell my parents I'm gay whatever
your problem is
minority anger it's not exactly the same
as a person next to you because
everybody has a different radiation and
if you can refine what's unique about
your problem one of the ways you refine
this is through the metaphor
then you have a Channel of uniqueness
and then you're doing something
that only you're doing
and uh and that's I think the only way
to get into this very crowded space
as a writer
so each of you have your problem
now you've got to come up with your
metaphor now what is a metaphor well a
metaphor is
not a simile it's something else a
simile is like or as my heart is like a
dying star
that's a simile
a metaphor is something that stands
apart from the problem yet is somehow
linked to its Secret
so now we need metaphors
for
your individual problems a metaphor is
the standard it is not the problem
itself so
the metaphor for
a lonely boy is not a lonely boy there's
a metaphor for an unattractive girl is
not an unattractive girl it's something
like the metaphor I'm like the problem
but not the problem itself it's like two
wires
you have the problem in the metaphor and
they have to get close enough for a
spark to jump across
and if they're too far apart there'll be
no spark and if they're on top of each
other there'll be no spark you you get
them like this tip them a little bit
you feel the Spartan make it off a
little more feel the smart and when your
theme and your metaphor are lined up
right
Sparks will go back and forth so you
have to tease them and and play with the
spark transcendental style is
essentially a withholding device most
movies lean towards you they lean
towards you aggressively with their
hands around your throat trying to grab
every section of your attention
these type of films lean away from you
and they use time and and as other
people would call it boredom
as a technique
[Music]
eventually if you're smart enough on how
you use these techniques now you're
doing something really rare you're
activating the viewer
and once the viewer starts to move on
his own
is so much more powerful if you
consistently withhold and now the viewer
is leaning towards you
now you have to I think in a certain
moment free them you know do something
unexpected
and Eda is the tracking shot at the end
you know and uh brison is just a burst
of music you know you know you you show
a movie for an hour and a half two hours
with no music at all
and often at the end boom a big blast of
Mozart what are you gonna do with
something that aggressive and the trick
of someone who can use transcendental
style it just suddenly frees them so
like the characters in the ozu's films
never show any emotion and all of a
sudden in wamo comes a big Blossom
emotion what are you going to do with it
now that he has totally conditioned you
not to expect it
is it going to put you off or is it
going to
Knock You Up A Notch and that's the idea
of the decisive action
and once you get that action and then
then after that
silence
isn't it really hard to go slow now that
we've rewired our brains to process
information at such a fast clip so you
can get the information very very fast
and now you're starting to get
multitasking information I said no no
it's in fact easier now to make a slow
film
because people are so geared
for a barrage of visual and audio
information that you just have to slow
down a little and you're disrupting them
a lot
is simply what happens
when you take a matter when you take a
problem and drive it through a metaphor
okay you have a problem the problem is
loneliness you have a metaphor taxi cab
driver shove your problem into the
metaphor what happens
well you have a guy who's drifting
around
he meets
a girl he can't have
but wants he meets a girl he wants but
can't have
he tries to kill the father figure of
one and fails so he kills the father
figure of the other and becomes a hero
that is the entire plot of taxi drivers
right there
and all that comes from is taking this
loneliness and shoving it through a taxi
cab and imagining what can happen
when you talk about withholding
techniques or Folsom techniques they are
both manipulations
but one is the active manipulation
whether and what is a passive
manipulation so if I'm actively
manipulating you
you do not have to do anything I will I
will do everything for you I will keep
you busy I will tell you how to feel at
every single moment
and um
but if I am
uh passively seeking your emotions I'm
you have to start to come toward me and
that starts to become your journey and
your journey will always be different
than your journey and your journey you
know whereas my active Journey it's
going to be the same for all of you I'm
going to make you all sort of you know
feel the same buzzes at the same time
and scream at the same time and but if
I'm doing a passive Journey
uh it will be different and
um and when people start to
fill out
the vacuum
they start to
um project themselves into it and uh and
then the kind of magical things start to
happen
and you can't really predict them uh
because
taken people to a place where they're
uncomfortable
and they're going to do something about
it and one of the things they can do is
get up and leave and the other thing
they can do is start to invest
themselves in this situation
and like if you if you create a
character
and you play this game where I I would
create a character that you identify
with
and I you know I set the hook bait the
hook you bite
and after about 45 minutes I've had the
hook in tight
and then all of a sudden he starts the
veer
and
a man you have thought worthy of your
identification starts to do things
that you don't approve of
now what do you how do you deal with
that
what adjustments are you making as your
identification is going awry
and on the end those adjustments that
you're making uh
are the real work of the film and I
don't I don't necessarily know what
adjustments everyone individual person
makes and and therefore you know when
people say what's the real meaning of
that I said I don't know you tell me you
know Iris DeMent has a great song called
Let the mystery be
and sometimes you know that's the
hardest thing for an artist to do is let
the mystery be I'm a big believer in the
oral tradition I do not think
screenwriting is part of the literary
tradition
it's a it's a form of
telling of Storytelling and so that
part and parcel of the process
is not writing but it's talking and
telling the story over and over again
and
you know you can have a script
that's extremely well written
and you can have the same story
poorly written and they can both be a
great film
so it isn't so much about the writing
itself as it is about the story every
time I'm evolving a story you start
making outline but other
what they call the Beats what are the 8
10 15 20 things that happen now you
don't really care what people say about
your idea
because they're not going to have that
much of value to save
what you really care about is the body
language all right you know do you have
the do you have them
you you can judge by
uh their posture
by
you know and all of a sudden you're
starting to lose them you know it's just
like a stand-up comic saying I'm losing
the crowd I'm losing This Crowd
and Raymond Chandler said once you know
uh if you get in trouble have somebody
with a gun and walk in because the
reader is going to be so grateful he's
there they're not going to ask why
and it's the same thing as true here I'm
telling you this story
and then I say and these two big black
guys drive up from wearing red suits in
a purple convertible
boom I got your back
I also not these no black dudes of the
purple convertible that I had to deal
with but I do have you back now I gotta
come on work them into the story and so
you find yourself as you tell the story
embellishing it in order to make it
better because you're losing the
audience
and also every time you tell it you can
see from your outline
where your
um different types of scenes are fallen
in
at physician scene comic relief
action scene
mystery scene you know boom boom boom
and if you've seen your outline you have
three acquisition scenes in a row you
know that's not going to fly
and if you try telling that you would
see that right then and there because
you start to tell a person three-act
positions things in a row and they're
going to get bored that's what I was
beginning to learn to ride I used to
even color code these outlines
by Exposition action humor uh Romance
so I can actually look at the outlines
in different colors and say wait a
second
you got three Exposition scenes in a row
here
and then you got a comedy and action a
comedy that's not you know squish them
around
and then you'll figure that out when you
tell it in person
and so if you can tell a story
for 45 minutes
and hold somebody I think you have a
movie
and uh and if you're not quite sure
you know and invite somebody for coffee
or a drink and start telling me your
story and then toward the end of it
you go up and go to the bathroom and
come back and don't resume it
if they don't ask you how the story
ended you don't have a story
and maybe your first outline
is just a few items long but when you
come back from that coffee or that beer
you re-outline it because you know
you've just thought of some other things
so maybe you had a little story with 10
10 scenes in it but now it's 15 scenes
oh don't tell it again
and if you own them you own them
and if you don't you have to come up
with something
you have to find those two guys in the
purple suits you have to find that comic
relief guy you have to be going down the
street and the beautiful woman falls out
of the window and dies in front of you
anything to get them back
um and then you you know and you say
well that kind of worked that the girl
the red dress and the yellow hair falls
down and cracks her skull open and they
really bought that how I wonder how you
can work that in the story
um and
so it built what I'm writing I try only
to think as a writer I think of a story
problem metaphor character plot dialogue
but I try not to think of images
and then when I come back to it as a
director now I think of images
and the image is not words
if I say to you glass of water
um that's three words that's not a glass
of water that's three words
here is a glass of water that's a
different thing that's a different kind
of idea and that's how you have to start
thinking if you're going to translate
words into images
to me there really is no script format
um
although you do a final draft tries to
mandate how a script looks
I I wrote my first script as chapters
without seeing numbers
You Know Travis buys a garden Travis
meets Betsy Travis drives and just a
little chapters I wrote first before in
this chapters
without without numbers
I wrote the new one in chapters without
numbers then of course
they are
um the
the line producer has to go through all
the work of dumb Rina because how do you
prepare a budget and a board without
numbers but for me it works better
without numbers
um
uh I've written a script in the past
tense
I've written a script in
um zowie language like comic book
language you know Bing Bang Boom all
that
each story
sort of tells you how it wants to be
written
and so don't get so hung up
on what they tell you a script is
supposed to look like
and if a script reads well that's all
that matters
and it's the same thing with
ass how many acts are there in a movie
well mostly the three because we live in
the past and the present in the future
we like to think in trials
but in fact some movies have five acts
some movies have one act
some movies have two Acts
you know and don't let anybody at any
school or any textbook tell you you have
to be three acts it doesn't have to be
and don't let anybody tell you you can't
have a scene
that's 10 minutes long where nothing
happens